four days ago in his inaugural address
Chicago's new mayor Brandon Johnson
celebrated and welcomed illegal aliens
to his City
soul of Chicago
tells us we will never close our doors
to those who come here in search of a
better life we must reject a zero-sum
formulation between investing in those
who have been here for decades and
supporting those who have been sit here
on a bus even this morning
we can do both Chicago
and we can all Thrive together
we can all Thrive together this is going
to be great but then the following day
the new Chicago mayor changed his tune a
little bit and he called the buses of
illegal immigrants Wicked and
unconscionable maybe he changed his tune
because Chicago residents don't want to
put up with endless streams of foreign
Nationals breaking the law and stealing
City resources maybe he changed his tune
because he thinks that only conservative
cities and states should have to deal
with illegal immigration that
immigration is great but only when it's
not in my backyard whatever the reason
he's wrong Mass illegal immigration is
wicked and unconscionable but the busing
program out of Texas is wonderful in
that it brings the reality of this crime
home to the people who cheer it on it
represents the first time in my lifetime
that conservatives have actually fought
back on the issue and done something
concrete to impel Democrats to stop it
it means conservatives are finally
willing to stop playing defense and
start bringing urgent political fights
to Democrats doors the only thing Wicked
and unconscionable they could come from
this is if we give up the fight before
we win I'm Michael knowlesist the
Michael Knowles show
again
[Music]
welcome back to the show
we have got a number of trans activists
calling on doctors to break the law and
prescribe puberty blockers and sex
change procedures to little kids now
that conservatives are getting really
tough and finally starting to use the
law to Outlaw these kinds of procedures
so we'll get to that in just one second
first though this immigration issue it's
not just Chicago that you're seeing this
in New York right now
you know there's been this policy of
taking the migrants who have been sent
on buses from the border states Texas
especially and then just putting them up
in hotels
because there's nowhere else to put the
illegal immigrants New York is saying
this is a catastrophe this is a disaster
why do we have to deal with this
well that's because New York is
encouraging illegal immigration
and when it was in Texas and when it was
in parts of California and that was all
fine but now that it's going into these
other places all of a sudden it's a big
terrible deal so they just keep doing it
this temporary measure has been keeping
them for months and months and months
now now nearly half of New York City
hotel rooms are filled with illegal
immigrants
half and New York city mayor Eric Adams
who's a big lib but he's at least
somewhat reasonable he's at least
somewhat open to reality he says this is
completely unacceptable because Adams is
pointing out that right now
New Yorkers
are set to foot an annual bill of 75
million dollars to put up border
crossers and illegal aliens in
Manhattan's Roosevelt Hotel just to use
one example that's a hotel I used to
stay at all the time when I would go
back to New York it's one of the most
historic hotels in New York
now filled with illegal aliens Adams
noted that the cost of illegal
immigration to New Yorkers who are
paying five million dollars every single
day
to deal with the migrants will exceed
4.3 billion dollars with a B when the
Lost tourism money comes in because when
when you fill up half of New York's
hotels with illegal migrants who aren't
paying a penny
well that's not only a cost to the
taxpayers but that's Revenue that is not
coming in from outside of New York
that's that's Revenue that's not going
to be spent at New York restaurants and
shops and Broadway plays
last week Eric Adams had 4 200 border
crossers and illegal aliens arrived in
New York more than 900 arriving in a
single day
in the cities having 13 to 15 migrant
buses arrive every single day this is
what it looks like for conservatives to
get tough some people have objected and
said look these are human beings and
they shouldn't be put on buses and sent
across the country Texas should just
deal with it
yeah these are human beings and they
shouldn't be encouraged to break our
nation's laws by cynical opportunistic
Democrats who never have to deal with
the cost of that
if you want illegal immigration to stop
from a purely humanitarian standpoint
there was an eight-year-old girl who
died in Biden Administration custody
just this week on top of another minor
17 year old who died a week or two ago
why because the Biden Administration
and the lives across the country have
encouraged these migrants to come surge
across the border
the only way to get that to stop even if
you don't care about the rule of law
even if you don't care about the
shifting demographics of America even if
you don't care about citizens being able
to say who gets to come and go
just from a purely humanitarian
standpoint you've got to convince the
liberals who encourage this stuff that
this is really bad for them and the way
to do that is to give people a free bus
ticket to the city that never sleeps
and to show them the true cost of of
illegal immigration right now 4.3
billion dollars and that barely
scratches the surface okay we've got to
drive this home we've got to give people
a clear message when you want to send
your friends a clear message you should
give them a call on pure talk right now
go to puretalk.com Knowles do you
remember the last time you got a free
phone started out feeling great and then
came the Hefty activation fees the
four-line requirements and of course
that binding contract Pure Talk is
giving you a free 5G Samsung Galaxy
phone without the feeling that you've
been duped when you switch to Pure talks
unlimited talk and text data plan that
comes with a mobile hotspot you will get
a 5G Samsung Galaxy for free that's
right unlimited everything at a fraction
of the price of Verizon ATT or T-Mobile
here's the thing you'll be on America's
Most Dependable 5G network not just a
similar network but the very same one
how do I know because I'm a customer
make the switch to Pure Talk the cell
phone Wireless company I am proud to
stand behind because they provide a
phenomenal product and they're proud to
stand behind our mission at the daily
wire pure talks us-based customer
service team helps make the switch in as
little as 10 minutes and you can even
keep your phone number go to
puretalk.com Knowles kwles for your free
Samsung Galaxy when you sign up for
unlimited talk text and unlimited data
that is puretalk.com Knowles Pure Talk
Wireless for Americans by Americans
Ron DeSantis has been among all of the
Republican Governors leading the charge
on wielding state power to drive these
points home really great news yesterday
HB 1438
Ron DeSantis signed this into law
it allows the state to quote fine
suspend or revoke the license of any
public lodging establishment or public
food establishment if the establishment
admits a child to an adult live
performance okay this seems to make
sense right we shouldn't we shouldn't
allow strip clubs and drag cabarets and
all the rest to perform obscene material
for children right
what's the consequence of this the
direct consequence of this we're already
seeing it is there was a pride event in
Tampa that was scheduled Tampa Pride on
the river it is canceled now and it is
canceled because the organizers don't
know if they're going to violate this
law
which first of all tells you everything
about these kinds of events when we're
told oh the pride parade it's just about
equality and fairness and Kumbaya and
we're all pretty much Will and Grace you
know what I mean man that's obviously
not true if that were true the pride
parade event would continue but with
these Pride Parade events always include
are weird dudes wear and leather making
obscene gestures and drag queens
jiggling and especially when you factor
in young people coming out to these
things it's obscene and so the the Tampa
Pride on the river admits yeah we're
putting on lewd and licentious
performances and that's not the only one
that DeSantis signed into law
DeSantis also assigned into laws uh a a
ban on transiting the kids
an anti-drag bill
and a bill uh telling boys that they
have to go to the boys bathroom and
girls that they have to go to the girls
bathroom in K-12 schools in public
facilities
basic stuff when we had a sane culture
even five years ago we would not have
needed laws to articulate these things
but as our culture spirals out of
control and becomes untethered from
reality as people stop having a shared
view of morality and just what
constitutes the nature of our world
you're going to have to spell these
things out a little more explicitly
the the best part about this kind of
legislation is that at least for now it
doesn't lay out every single thing
that that first bill that I was talking
about they got the Tampa Pride event
canceled it didn't explicitly list drag
performances
it just said adult performances should
not be performed for kids and people
will be fined and punished if they are
and the Tampa Pride felt bullied Tampa
Pride felt a little unsure of the
consequences it was going to face if it
if it gave the performance and said okay
better safe than sorry
that is what we want for years and years
Libertarians especially would say
politics is Downstream of culture and
there's some truth to that of course the
movies that we make and the the rituals
that we engage in are obviously going to
affect the the way that we view the
political community and the laws we pass
but that doesn't mean that law doesn't
have any effects on the culture and here
what you're seeing is that culture is
Downstream of the law if you have a
really open licentious legal system that
says anything goes then you're going to
get weirdo perverts jiggling around in
leather costumes for little kids and
then if you get a normal person like Ron
DeSantis who comes in and says Nah
we're very likely going to punish you if
you do weird stuff like that guess what
happens the culture changes and the
weirdos go back into their homes and put
on their weird performances for
themselves
this could be a real distinguishing
factor in a 2024 race
if right now you've got the two top
candidates Trump and DeSantis
DeSantis is running to the right of
trump on these LGBT drag queen trans
bathrooms kinds of issues
it's not that Trump has come out and
said I'm pro-trans bathroom or anything
like that
he just hasn't really focused on these
issues so this would be one place where
Ron DeSantis who right now is struggling
to some degree because
some establishment forces have glommed
onto his campaign really through no
fault of his own it's just because he's
not Donald Trump and the establishment
forces hate Donald Trump so DeSantis has
this perception that he's to the left of
Donald Trump if he can run to the right
of Donald Trump on an issue like
the trans stuff which really resonates
with voters if to say this can run to
the right of Donald Trump on say
abortion
not sure that he will you're just you're
not seeing the Trump campaign be totally
clear and articulate about its stance on
these issues then DeSantis might have a
shot though the numbers right now are
not moving in the right direction for
DeSantis they are moving in the right
direction for Donald Trump now speaking
of the LGBT community
I have just read the most nauseating
article
that I've read in in a long time
I don't have a waste paper basket or
anything near me so I'm going to try to
keep it together as I pull this out for
the show it is
an article by Wired Magazine this very
lengthy article profile
of Pete bootage
areas mayor Pete looking so he's looking
cool
he's looking so hip it says Pete bootage
Edge loves God beer and his electric
Mustang
sure the U.S Secretary of Transportation
has thoughts on Building Bridges but
infrastructure occupies just a sliver of
his voluminous mind oh I'm getting a I'm
getting a tingle up my leg
thrill
here's what they're saying I I encourage
you to read the whole profile it is
don't do it after you've just had a big
lunch I mean I would recommend you do it
on an empty stomach so this is how the
whole thing opens
the Curious mind of Pete bootage holds
much of its functionality and Reserve
even as he discusses railroads
derailing no they don't talk about
derailing railroads and Airlines down to
the pointless data that is his current
stock and trade the U.S Secretary of
Transportation comes off like a Mensa
black card holder who might have a
secret go habit that's a game that
mostly Asian people play or a three
second Rubik's Cube solution or a knack
for supplying off the top of his head
the day of the week for a random date in
1404 along with a non-condescending
history of the Julian and Gregorian
calendars that's how the piece begins
and it only gets crazier from there but
this is my favorite one
it's my favorite piece
I slowly became aware that his cabinet
job requires only a modest portion of
his cognitive Powers other mental
faculty other mental facilities no
kidding are apportioned to The Iliad
Puritan historiography and now scarred
spring though not in the original
Norwegian slacker
fortunately he was willing to devote yet
another apps in his Cathedral mind to
making his ideas about three Mighty
themes neoliberalism masculinity and
Christianity intelligible to me I'm not
going to talk about Buddha judge I'm not
going to diminish his uh
cathedral-like mind it's
to me the most distressing part of this
article is not what it says about our
absolute failure of a transportation
secretary it's like the easiest job in
any Administration and this guy has
somehow managed to screw it up by not
showing up for work and not fixing the
problems he was supposed to fix and
focusing on racist Bridges instead of
keeping our railroads secure so that
trains can move on them but I'm gonna
put that aside for a second the thing
that was most shocking to me here
was that this wired writer is impressed
that a member of the president's cabinet
has read The Iliad
how far has our culture Fallen that that
is now the sign of having gone above and
beyond in one scholarly Pursuits The
Iliad if we lived in a normal culture
every high school student would have
read The Iliad
now you need to be a Rhodes scholar
working directly for the president of
the United States to have read one of
the foundational works of Western
literature that basically reads like a
Marvel movie it's not even like like The
Iliad is some really abstruse philosophy
The Iliad is a war story and poem that's
really fun and exciting we are so
uncultured we are so ignorant we are so
male educated today that that is
impressive that a columnist that a
profile writer a journalist in Wired
Magazine says other mental facilities no
kidding are apportioned to The Iliad no
kidding yeah I hope
I hope the people running our government
have read like even the basic works of
our civilization ah these low
expectations
it's a failure of journalistic Integrity
of course but it's just pathetically low
expectations how long are we supposed to
continue as a republic if we live like
this if we don't know a damn thing about
anything and we're impressed when our
leaders can read
not
a good sign
speaking of expectations this is pretty
creepy Florida researchers
at University of Florida researchers
they were working on basically an
unrelated project and they discovered
that they can collect human DNA in the
air
they were just studying sea turtles and
and they noticed that they were
collecting a lot of human DNA because
quote we cough spit shed and flush our
DNA into all of these places and
countless more and then you just pick it
up
so what does this mean it means that you
don't need to worry so much if you sent
in your DNA spit sample to one of those
ancestry websites and then check listen
if they want to clone you they're going
to clone you you don't you don't need to
send them a spit sample to do that
we are not just hurtling toward our
dystopian future we are there
oh my goodness people can collect our
DNA just from the air yeah but think
about where we are already
we are under 24 7 surveillance
usually multiple kinds if you've got a
phone on you right now you probably do
if you're listening to the show if
you're sitting near a computer if you're
sitting in a neighborhood if you're
certainly if you're in an office right
now
if you have a TV in some cases
you are being spied on
all the time
and we we often think of this as the the
dystopian future oh can you imagine when
we get to this Terminator like place
we're already there
that dystopian future that we are all
dreading is now speaking of surveillance
you know the Jordan Neely killing on the
subway which is being called a murder by
all the libs and which is being called
heroic self-defense and the protection
of a community by conservatives so which
is it did this Marine did he go out
there because he's probably racist you
know all these guys they're racist he'd
go out there because he just wanted to
kill a poor innocent man who he just
wanted to moonwalk on the Subways
basically Michael Jackson but better
than Michael Jackson because he didn't
do the kids stuff
or was this guy protecting the subway
train from a career criminal who'd been
picked up at least 42 times who had
assaulted people who had given up a 60
something year old woman a black eye
well according to an eyewitness
it's the latter
eyewitness says I'm sitting on a train
reading my book and all of a sudden I
hear someone spewing this rhetoric he
said I don't care if I have to kill an F
I will I'll go to jail I'll take a
bullet
so not only threatening violence on
people saying I don't care
I don't care if I have to kill somebody
I'm not only going to be violent I'm
going to kill somebody
said everyone on the train was scared
for our lives nearly had 42 prior
arrests and an active warrant just a
couple years ago Neely attacked a 67
year old woman gave her a black eye and
a broken nose and then this hero
Marine comes in
and he
takes the guy down and the guy should be
given a key to the city and the guy
should be given an award and instead
they're going to try to throw him in
prison
what we can see from this is that
disfavored groups are judged on a curve
okay obviously if the races were
reversed here you wouldn't hear about it
it'd be totally fine no big deal
whatsoever but that's not what's
happening
what's happening is because this guy is
white because he was in the military
because the the career criminal who was
killed is black this guy is going to
have to be so buttoned up and perfect
you're going to have to have
eyewitnesses going even further than
this woman you're going to have to and I
hope this is what happened for this poor
Marine sake I hope that this guy this
Neely was so explicit in what he was
obviously likely to do on the subway I
will kill people if I am not taken down
by a marine right now and choked on the
ground I really hope that is the case
because in our unjust system
this Marine who this is an open and shut
Common Sense case in our unjust system
this guy
is going to have to be perfectly
buttoned up or he is going to get the
book thrown at him
now speaking of books a lot of people
when they go to buy cars they do so with
a big book of prices well you don't need
to do that anymore you got to go check
out karzing right now go to carzing.com
Knowles buying a new car can be a
stressful experience for anyone
especially if you're a first-time buyer
or have no credit before you walk into a
dealership and spend the whole day with
the crowds and the stress and the
potential not even to find a car you
need to check out carsing carsing is
completely changing the way you buy a
car online by partnering with Credit
Agencies lenders and over 25
000 dealers Nationwide karzing provides
you with everything you need before
stepping foot into a dealership you can
instantly pre-qualify online without
affecting your credit score and get
instant financing details including what
your down payment would be your monthly
payment term APR putting you several
steps ahead of other buyers once you
find the right car at your ideal budget
all you've got to do is bring your saved
deal voucher with you to the dealership
finalize your next it is so simple even
if you're not in the market for a new
car you should check out carsing anyway
it's like window shopping just poke
around you see what's available in your
area carsync helps make your experience
faster cheaper less stressful go to
carson.com skip all that guesswork
carzing.com Knowles
now
speaking of the culture
we've got a lot of leftism in in our
culture right now
and we've got a lot of grading on a
curve and all the rest of it the Buffalo
Bills cut punter Matt arraza has been
booted out of football and why is that
because of an allegation surfacing that
he participated in a gang rape of a
minor okay and this really ties in with
what we've been saying about the
disfavored groups here in our culture
the accusation is that he participated
in the gang rape of a minor while he
attended San Diego State University the
accuser filed a civil lawsuit against
reyez and three other men including two
former SDSU teammates then prosecutors
in San Diego's DA's office declined to
file criminal charges why why do they
decline to file charges because the guy
wasn't even there at the time
he couldn't have committed this crime he
wasn't even in the building at the time
according to Yahoo DA's office concluded
a raise that couldn't couldn't have led
the girl into the alleged gang rape
because he had left the home at about 12
30 a.m an hour prior to when evidence
suggested the alleged gang rape would
have occurred he wasn't even at the
party any more the DA's office says that
this girl did appear to have sexual
contact with a bunch of guys at this
party but that none of it appears to
indicate rape and in fact some of it was
caught on camera because we're being
surveilled 24 7 and it shows that her
story was
not true but this guy this football
player was already tried in the media
and his life is already ruined his
career is already ruined and that's that
and there are many many such cases
now one conclusion from this is
obviously people should have due process
we shouldn't have people tried for very
serious Crimes by Committees of of
professors or by hack journalists or
anybody else there's another side to
this story though which is
was co-education a mistake
I'm not saying in all cases I'm not
saying but
right now we have an educational system
that does not distinguish really in any
way between men and women including in
dormitories including in Suites in
dormitories there will be gender neutral
Suites so you're sharing a room with men
and women you're sharing a bathroom
that's been going on for 10 years that
was true when I was in college
and obviously you're sharing dormitories
and is that
I don't know if you put people who are
just brimming bags of hormones and then
you apply them with alcohol which is
what happens at every single college
campus and then the the lines of of
consent get a little bit blurry when
people can are no longer in command of
their rational faculties and so all of a
sudden you've got cases of regret which
then seem to be rape or one can make a
claim of rape even though
investigations and even surveillance
footage will show it it wasn't actually
a rape but was this
if we're talking about how the law is a
teacher and culture can be Downstream of
the law
wouldn't it make sense to just draw some
of these distinctions a little bit more
recognize that women are in fact the
weaker sex men ought to be chivalrous
when you put young men and women
together in certain situations and
they're there all the time and they're
drinking a lot and their things can
happen that are not conducive to their
virtue we talk about how we don't know
the difference between men and women
anymore because of the transgender issue
these issues started way before that and
so if men and women really are different
shouldn't we acknowledge that in all
sorts of places in our law speaking of
weird sex stuff
this is also a story that I've been
meaning to get to I'm glad we have time
to get to it right now uh in 2021 the
Utah governor
signed a bill requiring phones and
computers sold in the state to come
equipped with a filter that blocks porn
and you taught very recently has has
upped some of the legislation on
pornography but that was a really big
move that took place a couple of years
ago and the filter could be deactivated
but it would already be on the phones
and computers by default but the bill
hasn't gone into effect yet because the
bill only goes into effect if five other
states pass a similar law
and presumably this is not to put an
undue burden on the computer and phone
companies to have to do this just for
the state of Utah maybe that was the
Compromise there okay
I hope other states pass this because if
you want to protect young people
from
bizarre ideologies and Mal education and
weird sex stuff it's not enough to just
look at
the uh
transiting the kids procedures it's not
enough to just look at what's going on
in Elementary School classrooms it's not
enough to just look at I don't know
critical race Theory or men competing in
women's sports or all of that if you
really wanted to protect young people
you would just go after porn this is a
ubiquitous problem
the average age of being exposed to porn
is something like at 11 it can go down
as low as age eight
it's a big problem okay and people write
into this show all the time they say I
got hooked on porn my life has gotten
really screwed up because of it
go after that do Republicans have the
hutzpah to do it the libs obviously
don't they're very Pro porn they want
porn in the Public Square do the
conservatives have the husband to do
that
I don't know that they do now speaking
of weird sex stuff a trans activist is
calling on his fellow
trans identifying people
to break the law increasingly as the
governors come in and they say no more
transiting the kids no more puberty
blockers for kids no more sex change
procedures for kids
there are a number of transsexuals trans
identifying people
who say we've got to break the law pay
attention to the news lately and my life
has gone really great but unfortunately
there's a lot of people trans people
trans youth who are really suffering
right now and need our support like this
bill in Mississippi is absolutely
appalling to me the fact that the
government is overstepping it's about
like the government does not have any
right to legislate your gender identity
so if you're trans youth if you're a
trans adult don't need transition don't
hide don't be be as out there and as
bold as you possibly can be without
necessarily jeopardizing your own safety
I'm not saying you should do
be safe but like we need to stand up and
tell the government what for because
this is absolute uh don't need
transition if you're a medical provider
do everything you can to not obey the
laws these are unjust laws they have no
right to be existing and the moral thing
to do is to break them in whatever way
possible like I'm there's parts of me
that want to do things that I can't say
on here to people that are doing this to
people and it really makes me so sad and
this is the only thing that I hate in
life is through opposing suffering onto
other people who don't deserve it
because I know what that feels like so
I'm sorry for the late night rambling
ranting video and I know I try to make a
lot of positive uplifting count on here
but like it does have to be addressed
and there's a I tagged um content
creators in here go sign the petition in
Josh's bio uh go follow them too for gay
news and stand up do whatever it takes
March in the streets okay you get the
picture so what what this guy is calling
for is civil disobedience against what
he says are unjust laws now I know
people are going to have an emotional
reaction to this immediately when you
hear this
demented individual say that we need to
make sure that doctors violate the laws
so that they can go in and pump your
kids full of poison and chop their
genitals off I know that is gonna is
going to impel people to have a visceral
reaction and say bro
we're going to chase you out of town on
a rail or we're gonna lock you up in
prison or in a mental institution or
something like that and I get all of
that and
that that could be a discussion for a
later time
what we should deal with though is his
claim he's saying these laws that say
that you can't chop off kids genitals
they're unjust because
men can secretly be women or something
and that's my view and that's why we
need to stand up against those laws okay
if people stand up against those laws if
people do what this guy is saying
that is very sad for them because
they're mistaken about what Justice is
and they're mistaken about what human
nature is and it would be good to
correct these people and not allow these
pathologies to spread so much that we're
seeing these sorts of videos but if they
do that then we need to give them what
they ask for
if they do they say we're going to break
the law consequences come what may we
need to throw them into prison and
that's going to be the next step signing
the legislation is really really great
and it's good stuff for the Republican
Governors who have done and the
legislators who've done that but now
when people break the laws when they
when they
pedal porn to kids in elementary schools
when they trans the children we we're
getting reports that in Texas Children's
Hospital
some of these quacks perform sex change
procedures on kids as young as 11. okay
when these people break the law we need
to throw the book at them we are now
living in a system in which if you're a
good American Marine who has served your
country you're a good Patriot and you
protect people from a career violent
criminal with dozens and dozens of
arrests including for assault and you
protect them from a guy who's saying I'm
going to kill an F I'm gonna kill I
don't care I'm prepared to die you're
going to go to prison they're going to
throw the book at you but if you chop
off kids genitals you're you're not even
going to get a slap on the wrist okay
we're living in that system right now
and we need to
flip that situation we need to live in a
system that does not punish people for
doing good things but encourages them to
do good things we need to live in a
system that punishes people for doing
bad things very very bad things in this
case if you along with tens of millions
of people watched Netflix's hit show
making a murderer then you are going to
love daily wire Plus's new exclusive 10
part series with Candace Owens
convicting a murderer coming this summer
whether it is exposing black lives
matter or certain fallacies rather in
the healthcare industry regarding covid
Candace is unafraid to challenge The
Narrative when Candace found out that
key facts may have been omitted in
Netflix's series she set out to uncover
the truth behind the notorious Stephen
Avery case the result which is coming
soon is a new series called convicting a
murderer you will not want to miss it
right now there's never been a better
time to become a daily wire plus member
sign up now for convicting a murderer
and you will receive an early bird
discount of 35 off your daily wire Plus
Membership do not wait until the series
comes out this summer because the deal
won't last long you will also get all of
the other premium content from DW plus
including the greatest lie ever sold
what is a woman and Dr Jordan B
Peterson's series on the book of Exodus
join now dailywire.com subscribe to
become a member and see the truth when
it finally comes out my favorite comment
yesterday is from Deborah Gessner Who
Says Megan I'm a b-list actor who
married a prince so I could live my life
in privacy Markle is at it again that's
true and people tell you who they are
you should believe it now I want to hear
who you are and what you've got to ask
we will do that in the mailbag sponsored
by Pure Talk go to puretalk.com Knowles
kwles for your free Samsung Galaxy when
you sign up for unlimited talk text and
unlimited data
take it away
hey Michael this week at my job I was
forced to sit through yet another
nauseating Deni webinar during this
presentation they were talking about a a
great initiative to help underserved
communities
um with businesses that are trying to
thrive in those communities to make them
healthier which is a great initiative
but in doing so they were presenting
data that shows gross numbers from
white-owned businesses versus minority
owned versus black the problem as we
know is it looks terrible but it's
indisproportionate but in in context to
the ratio of the population it actually
is appropriate because only 13 percent
of the population is black despite what
they want us to believe so here's my
question why do such smart people
because I know that these are smart
people use data points that don't
actually support their claim as if they
think that we're too stupid to look up
the population
interested to hear your thoughts well
one because they think you're too stupid
to look up the numbers and two because
it doesn't matter
we live in a scientific age
and a scientistic age and so we
or living in a culture that believes
that statistics
and social science those are the only
ways to make arguments and this isn't
true in fact those are some of the
weakest ways to make arguments but
because we have degraded our view of
philosophy and Theology and morality
that's just what people do now and so
that's how you end up with kind of silly
arguments well because X percent did
this and 37 000 qubits of that dude
who's he wants us then therefore we need
to punish white people
say ah I don't that doesn't seem like a
very
compelling syllogism to me but that's
why they do that and it's also because
the Dai initiative has nothing to do
with Justice for anybody it's simply a
retributive regime to punish disfavored
groups including white people including
men including people who have a normal
view of sex and engage in normal sexual
behaviors and especially including
conservatives anybody who questions the
liberal regime and Dei itself so that's
all it's about
they could give you numbers they could
make up different numbers they could
show you a cartoon instead of showing
you numbers at all it doesn't matter the
point is always the same punish the
people that we don't like okay next one
hey Michael I'm a conservative Catholic
or at least I try my best to be one I
went to Franciscan University and Notre
Dame for undergrad and now I'm in the
Air Force for pilot training my question
is I feel that God is calling me to be a
father and a husband however I'm 27
years old now and ever since I was a
teenager I have struggled with same sex
attraction now I have dated girls in the
past and I genuinely did like them but
over the years the same sex attraction
seems to have gotten a bit stronger I do
go to confession fairly regularly and I
know that God is able to forgive my sins
when I have an honest confession but I
was wondering should I be so blessed to
find a woman who
would like to marry me
um do you think it's possible that she
could also forgive me for my sins
despite me having this history with
struggling with same-sex attraction
thank you very much for your time and
God bless really really good question
and it's a tough situation that you're
in I mean we all deal with difficulties
and you know various uh aspects of this
Fallen world that cause suffering that's
a tough one that's definitely a tough
one especially if you're saying look I
have this attraction but I I don't want
to pursue that attraction which is how
people used to view these things and now
we're told no if you have any sexual
attraction you have to indulge it all
the time and what you're saying is no I
have two Wills here you're just it'd be
it'd be like saying you know you you
want to eat the third cookie after
dinner but you're feeling a little fat
and so you want to your appetite says I
want to eat it but your rational will is
saying no I don't want to eat the cookie
and so you've got this this conflict
here and you're saying okay my appetite
is that I have attraction to people of
the same sex but my rational will tells
me that's not what my sex is for and
even even beyond that my rational will
is telling me I want to be a dad and I
want to have a normal family and I want
to and I do want a wife even if I'm not
totally sexually attracted to her I you
know I don't know for whatever other
reason perhaps you you want a wife okay
what you've said I think is important
where you say could she forgive me
because what you're saying here is I'm
not going to deceive this woman I'm
going to be upfront about these sexual
struggles that I've dealt with and I
think that's probably a good thing I
don't know I'm a little out of my depth
here I would say because for all of my
sins this is not one of the issues that
I've dealt with and I'm not a priest and
I'm not a counselor in this regard so I
would encourage you if you go to
confession talk to your priest about
this uh you know talk to other people
there's a great group a Catholic group
called what's it called courage maybe or
I forget the name which deals with
same-sex attraction and then you know
how to deal with that if you don't want
to pursue that kind of Lifestyle
um so I would I would talk through all
of that and yeah I wouldn't I wouldn't
deceive anybody but if if we're living
in a culture in which is so sexually
perverse through often no fault of of
people you know people who've been
exposed to porn at a young age and they
get into some kind of weird porn desire
or some you know
I don't know you're like furries or
something like that I mean people's
brains have been kind of melted and so
a great many people are dealing with
sexual disorder to some degree maybe not
the exact same one that you have but to
some degree
and so if we tell all those people well
you can't have a normal life well then
there goes civilization and if there is
such a thing as a gay gene which I'm not
totally sure that there is but if
there's some biological aspect of
homosexuality uh compared to a cultural
aspect then presumably guys who have the
same sex attraction have been getting
married to women now we have to specify
for all of human history so it has been
done I think you know taking these
things seriously looking at yourself in
the mirror and trying to deal with them
in a rational way is uh is really good
and really healthy and uh so I would
encourage you to seek out those
resources and then look to honesty and
then it's not up to me to see if a woman
can look past that it's up to the woman
next question
hey Michael big papa long Necker here
big fan of the show I've got a really
pressing question in regard to in
regards to Leah Thomas or William Thomas
um how has the nickname Willie Thomas
not caught on yet uh just seems like a
big missed opportunity there
um
so I thought you could weigh in on that
also just wanted to say a big fan of
your book speechless
do they get it did it ding
well anyways that's all for now thanks
that might be the best question I've
ever thank you it was a little it was a
little delayed but that's okay
that was a really powerful question
though I I do have to dispute your
suggestion in that
from what I've read from the news
reports of all the nicknames that that
guy could have
I don't think that one would be apt any
longer what do I know I don't know I
don't know I don't really want to know
anymore okay next question hey Michael
I'm currently reading through the Dune
series by Frank Herbert I think they're
phenomenal science fiction novels and I
was wondering if you'd ever consider
diving into science fiction of any kind
on your series the book club on prageru
I think it sparked really interesting
conversation because a lot of Science
Fiction is very heady very philosophical
and explores themes of human nature
um so I'm looking forward to seeing what
you have to say and I would absolutely
love to see science fiction on the book
club
funny you say that I'm in California
right now filming several episodes of
the book club we will have those coming
out shortly we had a lot of great guests
it was a lot of fun uh
I don't want to do science fiction on
the book club I'm not denigrating
science fiction as a genre many of my
friends who are erudite and serious
readers they love science fiction I just
can't get into it but I guess that's one
of the reasons that we should do it
because people love sci-fi and just
because I don't there's no reason that I
shouldn't try to expand my mind and I
shouldn't give the people what they want
so that's not better you can recommend
good Sci-Fi for me to read we can do it
I don't even know where to begin I guess
I should read Dune okay we've got a lot
more questions here
we've got how about this little tease
this will be just like a little bit of a
tease for the member block question from
Renata
says Michael recently our family found
ourselves stumped on acupuncture is it
Unholy or is it innocent enough I just
thought it's pressure points and it
always had a way of calming me down
feeling almost like a deep relaxing
massage and I've recently been reading
the benefits it could have to fertility
but when they start talking about Chi
and stuff I just don't know what to
think is acupuncture Unholy praying for
you and your family please send some
prayers our way on us getting started
with our own family well I certainly can
do that Renata
and I will give you my answer on
acupuncture but only in the member block
the rest of the show continues now you
do not want to miss it become a member
use code Knowles Canada wlas at checkout
for two months free on all annual plans
[Music]